A tsunami of questions flew out of the mouths of children
who the world didn't think were interested.
And they themselves had not known they cared.
And as they wrote and debated,
rather than seeing the films as artifacts,
they began to see themselves.
I have an aunt who is a wonderful storyteller.
In a moment she can invoke images
of running barefoot on Table Mountain and playing cops and robbers.
Quite recently she told me
that in 1948, two of her sisters and my father
traveled on a boat to Israel without my grandparents.
When the sailors mutinied at sea in a demand for humane conditions,
it was these teenagers that fed the crew.
I was past 40 when my father died.
He never mentioned that journey.
My mother's mother left Europe in a hurry
without her husband, but with her three-year-old daughter
and diamonds sewn into the hem of her skirt.
After two years in hiding,
my grandfather appeared in London.
He was never right again.
And his story was hushed as he assimilated.
My story started in England
with a clean slate and the silence of immigrant parents.
I had "Anne Frank," "The Great Escape,"
"Shoah," "Triumph of the Will."
It was Leni Riefenstahl
in her elegant Nazi propaganda
who gave context to what the family had to endure.
These films held what was too hurtful to say out loud,
and they became more useful to me
than the whispers of survivors
and the occasional glimpse of a tattoo
on a maiden aunt's wrist.
Purists may feel that fiction dissipates
the quest of real human understanding,
that film is too crude
to tell a complex and detailed history,
or that filmmakers always serve drama over truth.
But within the reels lie purpose and meaning.
As one 12-year-old said after watching "Wizard of Oz,"
"Every person should watch this,
because unless you do
you may not know that you too have a heart."
We honor reading, why not honor watching with the same passion?
Consider "Citizen Kane" as valuable as Jane Austen.
Agree that "Boyz n the Hood," like Tennyson,
offers an emotional landscape and a heightened understanding
that work together.
Each a piece of memorable art,
each a brick in the wall of who we are.
And it's okay if we remember Tom Hanks
better than astronaut Jim Lovell
or have Ben Kingsley's face superimposed onto that of Gandhi's.
And though not real, Eve Harrington, Howard Beale, Mildred Pierce
are an opportunity to discover
what it is to be human,
and no less helpful to understanding our life and times
as Shakespeare is in illuminating the world of Elizabethan England.
We guessed that film,
whose stories are a meeting place
of drama, music, literature and human experience,
would engage and inspire the young people participating in FILMCLUB.
What we could not have foreseen
was the measurable improvements
in behavior, confidence and academic achievement.
Once-reluctant students now race to school, talk to their teachers,
fight, not on the playground,
but to choose next week's film --
young people who have found self-definition, ambition
and an appetite for education and social engagement
from the stories they have witnessed.
Our members defy the binary description
of how we so often describe our young.
They are neither feral nor myopically self-absorbed.
They are, like other young people,
negotiating a world with infinite choice,
but little culture of how to find meaningful experience.
We appeared surprised at the behaviors
of those who define themselves
by the size of the tick on their shoes,
yet acquisition has been the narrative we have offered.
If we want different values
we have to tell a different story,
a story that understands that an individual narrative
is an essential component of a person's identity,
that a collective narrative
is an essential component of a cultural identity,
and without it it is impossible to imagine yourself
as part of a group.
Because when these people get home
after a screening of "Rear Window"
and raise their gaze to the building next door,
they have the tools to wonder who, apart from them,
is out there
and what is their story.
Thank you.
(Applause)